thank you so much for joining us today
my name is andrew olson and i will be
your host and moderator for today
so our next speaker is uh is a great
guide for us and is very familiar with
this topic dr eric sizer is one of our
outstanding
senior field application scientists
with kaijan digital insights and he's
located in the dc metro area
eric has a master's degree in
bioinformatics and a phd in functional
genomics his previous research focused
on pediatric cancer biology at the
children's hospital of philadelphia the
comparative oncology of genomic
alterations in dog cancers at nc state
university and cancer pharmacogenetics
at unc as you can see his presentation
is titled translational genomics putting
the pieces together from variant calling
to biological insights and with that i
will hand it over to erica are you with
us yes andrew and awesome thank you for
the introduction uh good afternoon
everybody so as andrew mentioned my goal
today is to demonstrate to everybody
essentially how we can move from a
scenario where we're starting off with
fast q files from sequencing we're going
to call variance filter and prioritize
variance and then define some biological
interpretations from some specifically
loss of function variants in a cohort of
samples
so before i begin
again a quick legal disclaimer the
kyogen products shown here are intended
for molecular biology applications these
products are not intended for the
diagnosis prevention or treatment of a
disease
so for today's exploration of what we're
going to focus is on a specific case
study of interest and this case study is
focusing on lynch syndrome as many of
you may be familiar with lynch syndrome
is a heritage hereditary condition
characterized by high risk of various
cancer types and typically it manifests
in the context of germline variants in
one of the many dna mismatch repair
genes
so in particular we've identified a
study here that is looking at surveying
uh for pathogenic variants in hereditary
cancer syndromes
with patients that have lynch syndrome
so we're doing some germline and gs
sequencing in this study in particular
the authors used utilized a targeted
panel and um their focus was on
just identifying and trying to highlight
some variants across a cohort of 84
samples which may have variants of
relevance for disease pathogenesis
so in our context today we wanted to
choose a study in particular because
we're going to illustrate how not only
can you utilize your own data but you
can also utilize public data to do some
translational research as well
so for today our focus is going to be on
three main areas first of all data
analysis how we can efficiently retrieve
and process fastq data with accurate
variant identification
secondly interpretation how we can take
a set of variants and rapidly assess
both sample variants for disease
relevance and pathogenicity and lastly
for the discovery side of things how we
can combine results from a cohort of
individuals and contextualize variant
biomarkers with other public data sets
to do these three steps we're going to
utilize three of kaijin software
products one is
for analysis at a clc genomics workbench
for interpretation we're going to use
kyogen clinical insights interpret
translational and for discovery we're
going to utilize ingenuity pathway
analysis
and so for the first product clc
genomics workbench essentially what this
tool represents is the ability to
process raw ingest data and get to
various endpoints so in our focus for
today we're going to be talking about
dnac analysis on the targeted panel and
in that context that endpoint would be
calling variants
but the software platform also supports
other
research endeavors if you're generating
let's say rna-seq data you want to look
at gene expression or fusion information
the platform can support that as well
now in this particular slide what we're
going to first start off by illustrating
is actually the endpoint of where we
want to get to within the genomics
workbench
so on my screen in particular towards
the center you'll notice two key areas
the first one at the top is essentially
a visualization of a particular variant
of interest within my data set
so at the top i have a pile up of all
the reeds identified at this variant
locus that gives me some degree of
looking at the actual sequencing
evidence for a variant of interest
next line here i have the focus of a
particular deletion that we've
identified and lastly on the bottom here
we have an annotation to the
amino acid changes that would occur
based on that specific variant
concurrently at the bottom of the screen
what we have are a list of all the
variants that have been identified in a
given sample and we have a table of
annotation for those variants the type
of variants various metrics with regards
to coverage and frequency within samples
gene level information and predicted
amino acid changes so ultimately through
the use of workflows as we'll see today
within the software we can very quickly
and easily get to accurate variant calls
in this case for germline samples or
also in the context of cancer research
if you're working with somatic samples
as well get to those variants of
relevance in your samples very easily
now to do this we're going to do a
couple of key steps within the software
itself the first one being to download
reference information and import or
sequencing reads now again this can be
in the context of as we're going to do
today utilizing public data or
conversely if you have your own
sequencing data importing that as well
then when we talk about specific
targeted sequencing obviously there are
regional information uh that we're going
to want to bring into the software as
well so we're going to want to import
our panel specific information
and then from there what we're going to
discuss is the dnaseq workflow itself
which will take us essentially in
a single dialog to do all the processing
necessary to move from fast q files to
called accurate variants and then from
there we can parlay into
interpretation now for today in
particular because we are working with
uh germline sequencing um just some of
the steps that will be included in the
workflow that we're going to utilize is
we'll be initially trimming of the fastq
files to make sure we have accurate and
high quality sequence to begin with
then we'll go through the steps of
mapping to a reference genome and
various alignment refinement steps
the next step will be to call variants
and then annotate them uh with
transcriptional information as well as
uh variant database information and do a
number of filtering steps
and then from there we'll cover it
generating various qc reports in
particular when we talk about targeted
sequencing coverage reports are
oftentimes very useful in making sure we
have enough sequence to accurately
detect variants
and then lastly kind of exploring the
variants themselves
now just a quick side note that if we
were to be running the same process on
somatic samples that there are scenarios
where within our workflows we also have
additional capabilities that you might
want to employ uh such as identifying
copy number variants calculating tumor
mutation burden and also interrogating
uh microsatellite instability status as
well
so really the software itself is a very
flexible platform the workflows that
we're going to discuss today are
those that can be utilized out of the
box with the software but they offer
also offer a degree of customizability
as well
so really what i want to walk you
through within the software briefly
today is the key steps to generate our
set of called and accurate variants
through clc genomics workbench and
that's going to involve again a few main
steps first of all downloading necessary
reference information
downloading our sequencing data itself
again we're going to pull data from this
study on lynch syndrome so we're going
to pull it from the sequence read
archive
if we were to import our own samples we
would do that step as well and then also
bring in targeted information for our
panel of interest
and then very lastly running a workflow
to
call our variants and get our endpoint
to transition into interpretation
so what i'd like to do now is to switch
over into the genomics workbench and
again i'm just going to quickly walk you
through some of the steps i just
mentioned
so this is the primary interface of the
software and we're going to show you how
you can quickly and easily accurately
call variants using this interface now
for everything that i'm showing today
i've actually run the analysis locally
on my machine so we can in fact
accommodate local analyses on a laptop
or a desktop
when you begin to start interrogating
larger sets of data larger cohorts of
samples there are also various
deployment options outside of a local
installation such as employing a server
for added compute power and also
deploying workflows on the cloud as well
so really how you utilize the workbench
is very flexible but ultimately
regardless of your deployment you're
able to actually run the analysis
directly through
this desktop interface
so as i mentioned with regards to any
ngs based analysis the first step we're
going to do is capture the reference
information
and if you direct your attention to the
top right corner of the screen the clc
genomics workbench makes this step very
easy
we simply need to click on references
and what we've done here is kaijan has
actually curated sets of reference
information that will be
useful for the various workflows that we
offer in the software
and for today's example in particular
i'm going to utilize this hg19 refseq
set for references
now through a singular download here
what i will capture is the genome
sequence itself
in addition to that information with
regards to the transcriptome in the
context of refseq
and then as you can see here other
third-party database information db snip
information clinvar information and
information from thousand genomes as
well
so by simply clicking this download
button i will generate all the necessary
reference information that i need to run
my analysis
with that step already done
the next step that i would do is one of
two things if i'm going to work with my
own samples i'll show you how we can
import those in a minute but again for
our example with lynch syndrome we're
utilizing public data and very nicely
again if you direct your attention to
the top right corner of the screen the
workbench has a built-in downloader for
pulling
fastq information from the sequence read
archive
so very simply here i can click download
search reads in sra
and at this point what i would go ahead
and do
is i can pull in a specific accession
number for a sample or in my case
i can paste in here the project
accession number
simply click
search and what i will capture from the
search again recall within this study i
mentioned that there are 84 samples
within this cohort
so now we have all of these 84 samples
listed here
and for any of them we can first and
foremost select them
we can show the metadata for these
samples so we have now a table for the
samples i selected from the study a set
of descriptors again various accession
information
information regarding to the project so
here you can see
we have a 94 gene panel that we're
working with
and then in addition to that as i would
scroll further along this table we will
get sample specific information the
isolate the age of the sample the sex
and any additional details that might be
included
within this study
so that gives us some context to what
these samples are
now for any sample of interest i would
have the ability simply to select that
sample or select multiple samples
and simply click download reads and
metadata here and that will get the data
directly into my software so there's no
need to move externally to capture my
sequencing data from a public repository
now with that simple step out of the way
i just want to diverge a second and talk
about quickly how if you had your own
sequencing data you could bring that
into the software
and in this scenario again it's a very
easy process where we would go to a
section here for import
and if we let's say had illumina
sequencing data we could select the
option here for illumina we can take in
either your single under your paired end
reads and very simply get that into the
software
the other thing that we would do with
this import as well is that we can bring
in information with regards to any
primers let's say that we use on your
particular panel of interest
and in addition to that we can bring in
track based information or the bed file
noting our targeted regions
so again very simply through a couple
clicks in the dialog you can get your
necessary reference information and both
your sample and experimental uh specific
information into the software quite
easily
now when we bring this information into
the software you'll notice to the upper
left-hand side of the software we have
this navigation area essentially this
represents the directory structure uh
within the software and you'll note here
in today's example i have a folder
created for lynch syndrome data
and under that one of the
fastq files that i've downloaded from
the sequence read archive
and what i can do is i can open that
file up um i can look at the fastq file
again lots of information here so this
is now a scenario where at this point
we're ready to process the sample itself
and to do so where we will refer to is
the bottom left corner of the screen
in particular in this section
we have sets of individualized tools
such as tools for mapping or variant
detection or various filtering or
annotation steps
but what i want to highlight today are
these ready-to-use workflows
so essentially these represent a
scenario where we have built out
pipelines for an analysis that do all
the necessary steps to process your data
and you simply have to go through a
singular dialogue to process one or more
samples
now in this context when we talk about
variant detection
tied to dan's talk earlier we do offer
actually pre-built optimized workflows
for the various chia seed panels that
are offered through kaiogen
and then in additional to that we offer
various workflows in place for whole
genome sequencing exome sequencing and
again in the context of what i'm doing
today
we have a targeted panel that we're
going to look at for identifying
germline variants
so outside of this again we would have
various tools in place for again doing
things like mapping reads to reference
variant detection what have you so
really you have the ability to utilize a
workflow process sample in a
standardized fashion very quickly or do
more exploratory analysis process the
data in a stepwise fashion using
individualized tools
now just to show you how easy it is to
both
interrogate a workflow and also run a
workflow
i'm going to pull up a copy of the
workflow that i've created today and
when we look at these workflows
essentially they can be distilled into
three main types of things the green
boxes represent inputs for the analysis
the three tiered boxes represent
specific tools that are being run
and the blue slack maybe purple color
boxes they represent outputs from the
workflow
and now to quickly kind of review what's
going on in my workflow for today we
have initial trimming steps that we do
we have mapping steps for the alignment
there will be then various steps here
that we do to refine the alignment so
we'll do
structural variant calling a local
realignment and then from there we'll
transition into a variant detection step
now everything that we would do
downstream here would essentially relate
to various tools that are in place to
both annotate and filter your variants
such that when we get to our set of
called variants as a result of this
workflow that we have accurate data
being reported
now one final thing to note with these
workflows is that again they are
flexible you can build your own
workflows you can add tools to existing
workflows and you can also
modify and lock down any parameters of
interest within a workflow
so at this point if i'm ready to run the
workflow very simply what i would do is
come to the bottom right corner here i
would click the run button and now we'll
essentially walk through a dialog where
let's say we can take one of our samples
of interest
or i could take multiple samples and i
can batch that
and then
all the available parameters that we
need to enter can be selected throughout
this dialog and in this case many of our
pre-built workflows actually require
very limited interaction
you can modify that to expose any
parameters you want but here i would
essentially choose my reference data in
this step
the next step if i had any pseudogene
information for trimming which i don't i
would import that here and essentially
everything else in the workflow has been
optimized already such that i don't need
to specify any additional parameters
so at this point what i would do is just
choose a location to save my results
click finish and again you know i'm
running this locally these samples uh
targeted panels so smaller data ran uh
well under an hour and again if you have
larger cohorts of samples or larger data
overall you can explore our both server
based options and our cloud engine based
options as well
so at this point
i've gone ahead and i've run the
workflow in advance just for time
purposes and let's take a look at some
of the outputs so
in my navigation area here i've
designated a folder for the outputs of
the analysis
you'll see there is a subfolder here
capturing different qc reports so in
particular in this scenario i might have
a general qc of my fastq sequence uh
information with regards to trimming and
mapping and structural variant detection
but what i want to highlight very
quickly is just a coverage report again
when we're doing variant detection
understanding coverage within our
samples is very important
and when i open this report what i'll
see very nicely is that in fact we have
high overall coverage over 600 reads per
sample
the median coverage is very similar
and when we look at the percent of
targeted regions that have a certain
threshold of coverage again
just about all of our regions here have
a coverage of 30 or greater and on
average 600 reads per locus
so this gives us some context to know
that we have appropriate sequencing
depth to hopefully get a good sense of
the variance within our sample
now there are other various pieces of
output for this analysis typically you
would find that under track data you can
get the mapping information the
pre-filtered variants
and a number of other things but really
the key endpoint that i want to show
everybody is this genome browser based
view
and this is a very nice integrated view
where again similar to what i showed on
the slides
at the bottom of the screen here what we
have is a table of all the called
variants
within this table again we have
positional information zygosity coverage
frequency
metrics related to variance confidence
from the caller
and towards the end of this information
relating to again annotation of the
specific experience identified
so for any of these variants they're
dynamically linked to the genome
browser-based view above such that i
could come in the table i could focus on
this particular deletion it's in the uh
mlh
so genome note for lynch syndrome
and as i click on that row within the
table now what i'll see is a view of the
mapping at the top here that denotes
coverage
i'll see a positional information of the
variant allele itself here so we're
dealing with a deletion of two
nucleotides
and then as i would scroll down we can
see that it's within a targeted region
using this blue bar here
and then also look at the expected amino
acid change based on this variant
so ultimately within the workbench
through a couple of easy steps i can
import all my necessary reference
information my sample information and
very quickly run a workflow that
accurately calls variance in my sample
of interest
now at this point what i'd have the
ability to do is export the data and we
can export this data in a number of
different formats we can export a table
of variants or a vcf file we can export
pdfs for any variant level reports
and also of note within the software we
actually have a built-in exporter to
transition our
variant calls from clc genomics
workbench to hygiene clinical insights
interpret translational and in fact
let's go ahead and jump back into the
slides
and at this point we can talk about our
next step which is variant
interpretation
and so for this process typically our
starting point is going to be a vcf file
where we have a large set of variants
and our goal is to essentially utilize
information to both filter and
prioritize variants in our sample or our
cohort examples
and to do this we're going to rely on
the kaiogen knowledge base
and essentially what this represents is
a massive effort of curation uh as biata
alluded to kaijin has a large curation
team where we are continually going
through the literature and capturing the
relevant variant information found in
studies and in addition to that we
incorporate multiple third-party
databases to help build our
understanding
and so within the software itself when
we run in this case a particular sample
from our cohort through kaijin clinical
insights interpret translational what we
are going to get back is a table of
filtered and prioritized variants
and in particular here one useful
feature within the software is that we
can take all the evidence that we find
for a variant from the literature
curation from third-party databases from
different uh functional effect
calculations and actually utilize
acmg-based guidelines to compute a
pathogenicity classification
so within this table itself that will be
a result for a sample analysis we can
see here that the mlh1 gene the nbn gene
in particular are red that denotes a
classification of pathogenicity whereas
we might see other variants that are
white that are unknown significance and
then green perhaps benign
now for each variant we'll also have a
table of annotation and very nicely
within this table since we're looking at
germline data we would be able to see
are any of these variants observed
within the hdmd database as well
now
from this table itself for any variant
of interest what we'd have the ability
to do is essentially come in and look at
the different pieces of criteria that
were used with the acmg guidelines to
essentially generate a classification of
this variant being pathogenic and so
again here we're focusing on what i
showed in clc that deletion in the mlh1
gene
and we can see their various criteria
that have varying degrees of strength
that would suggest that this variant in
the sample is pathogenic
now along with this classification what
we will also generate is the
bibliographic information as well so all
the curated literature that we have for
this particular variant of interest and
i'll actually go through this in a
little more detail within the software
but the final thing that i want to just
showcase to everybody is very nicely
when in this context we're talking about
germline variants
we have the ability to link out to hgmd
and through kind of the table we saw
earlier we'll be able to get at the full
set of information found within hdmd as
well
so what i'd like to do now is actually
go ahead and show everybody how we
interrogate this within the software
so i've just opened up kaijin clinical
insights interpret translational and
this is a web-based tool
so i've already gone ahead and analyzed
my vcf file from a sample of interest
this is the ls9 sample from the study
and the analysis itself very simple it
takes a couple of minutes to set up and
run
once it's run our key set of results
again at the bottom of the screen here
represent this table of variants that
have been uh filtered and prioritized so
for each variant
we'll have a row of information with the
c dot pdot nomenclature the phenotype
that's most associated based on the
information curated in the knowledge
base you can see there are a number of
variants here associated with lynch
syndrome
we'll have its most common mode of
inheritance again defined by what we
know in the literature
we'll have information relating to the
functional impact
we can see here that this variant i'll
focus on uh the gt deletion that's a
frameshift mutation
we also have another pathogenic mutation
in nbn and that's a stop gain
we'll also have other information
related to kind of impact prediction the
cad score here we can see
is very high for these two pathogenic
variants we can also look at population
frequencies across variant databases
and again lastly here we'll have the
hgmd information in the final column
now in this context for any variant of
interest what we would have the ability
to do is one of two things
as we select a variant in the table
what will happen is you'll notice the
top of the screen changes
and within the top of the screen in
particular
will have again variance specific
details towards the left hand side
and towards the right we can see the
computed classification based on acmg
guidelines
so here i can quickly look at the
evidence for pathogenicity and also
against pathogenicity for a given
variant of interest
in this context though oftentimes i
might want to look at this information
in further detail and to do so once i
have a variant selected
i can click open
and now i can look
at the explicit criteria that were
utilized
to establish that this variant in fact
is a pathogenic variant
for each of these pieces of evidence we
have an associated criteria id a
strength and for those
pieces of evidence that tie into the
literature um we'll also quickly be able
to link out to a bibliography that has
the associated reference information
now
as i mentioned the knowledge base also
focuses on curating literature as well
as incorporating third party database
information
so for any variant that we identify we
can actually get at the full spectrum of
literature that's been captured in
relation to this variant simply by
clicking this view bibliography button
and what i want to highlight here very
quickly is that we can filter
let's say the results based on different
categories of studies of interest
and very nicely here just to show you
kind of the frequency and the nature of
updating our knowledge base and our
literature curation efforts this second
article here actually is the article
from which we've captured these lynch
syndrome samples so that shows up we've
curated that through our
efforts
and then also very nicely we actually
have even a more recent publication so
this is from june of this year uh that
also identifies this uh variant in a
slightly different context
and for any of these we can very nicely
link out to pubmed and interrogate the
article in further detail
so overall when we are in the context of
interrogating a single sample what
kaijin clinical insights interpret
translational allows us to do is very
nicely go through a process where we can
take in a vcf file we can utilize the
rich set of information in the knowledge
base and help us prioritize those
variants that may be pathogenic in our
given uh
study of interest or our sample of
interest
now
so far we've looked at this in the
context of a singular sample
but what i do want to note is that also
in our study remember we are dealing
with a cohort of 84 samples with lynch
syndrome
so the software also provides a
mechanism not only to identify samples
one at a time but also i
analyze a cohort of samples
and so what we're looking at in the
slide here is actually that analysis
looking across all 84 samples
and we've set it up to identify those
variants that appear in two or more
individuals within this cohort
so
really this table itself that we're
looking at in this slide is very similar
to what we've seen already in the
software the key difference here is that
under this cases column
we do flag up how many samples with the
black line have a particular variant of
interest and here we can see across the
cohort of 84 samples not only do we see
variants in
mlh1 in particular that are recurrent
but also msh2 again two genes notably
associated with mismatch repair
so really at this point then just to
highlight how we process this cohort of
samples we have a filtering cascade that
allows us to set different criteria to
hard filter out variants of interest
based on different criteria i'll go over
that in a minute and so let's go ahead
and quickly jump back into the software
i'm now going to switch my results over
to those from the full cohort of 84
samples
and again the results from this once
loaded will look very similar the key
difference here with the table at the
bottom is that for each variant now we
can mouse over these black bars and see
which individual samples
show that given variant of interest
and in addition to that
again just like with the initial
analysis for any variant i can open up
the details i can view the bibliography
i can link out for instance to hgmd get
the information there
so it's very flexible
but in the context of analyzing cohort
samples
what might be relevant is to actually do
some filtering steps
so we have this customizable filtering
cascade that will allow us to filter
variants based on common confidence
based on how common they are in the
general population
characteristics related to deleterious
nature of a given variant and also just
characteristics on the cohort so again
as i mentioned i filtered this down to
identify those variants that are
pathogenic or likely pathogenic that
show
recurrence in at least two out of the 84
samples
so really this filtering cascade you can
come into any section here
you can see here that i've selected this
for two samples of the 84
in the filter
and as we go down this list what we can
see is using what i've defined as a
filtering cascade we've gone from a
total of over a thousand variants
down to 15 potentially pathogenic and
likely pathogenic variants of interest
so
at this stage
what we can do now is actually take this
information that we've gained we've
generated a set of pathogenic likely
pathogenic variants in the cohort as a
whole
and we can export this information in a
number of ways
so if you direct your attention to the
right-hand side of the screen
there is an export button so for any
cohort or sample-based analysis
we can export a vcf or we can export
tabular data we can include
any number of information
in columns relating to that variant
itself you can see here just general
positional information uh different
predictions from sift
cad as we talked about earlier
and then also annotation with different
variant databases like hgmd as we talked
about
cosmic
omim just to name a few
but also from the screen what we would
have the ability to do is actually
export this data into ingenuity pathway
analysis and the goal here
is to essentially take the set of gain
or loss of function variance within
genes found within this cohort and try
to do some biological interpretation of
what
gain or loss of function means for this
specific gene set
so at this point this takes us to the
final aspect of today's talk which is
discovery
and so what we're looking at here are
kind of the end results of the analysis
that i did on this set of gain or loss
of function variance in the cohort of
lynch syndrome patients
where essentially we're looking at a
heat map here
and within this heat map we have our set
of genes
this first column here represents the
sam or the cohort itself of my study and
within this cohort we can see each gene
has a green colored cell that represents
a loss of function in the set of genes
here again mlh1
a lot of fancy family of genes uh we can
see bronchi too as well
and then in addition to this first
column we see a number of additional
columns
and what these additional columns
represent are actually gene expression
studies from over 90 000 public studies
that we have curated and pre-analyzed in
ipa
and the studies that are specifically
within this heat map represent those
studies in which we see at the gene
expression level a similar subset of
this set of genes in my loss of function
study that show
a decrease in expression that would have
a similar kind of activity impact than
what our loss of function variance and
we can interrogate the contextual
details of all these different public
studies to understand you know where
else is the signature of loss of
function identified across a large
spectrum of different public studies
related to cancer
so how we actually got to this point is
that we utilize what we call the core
analysis within ingenuity pathway
analysis so
much like hygiene clinical insights
interpret translational
ingenuity pathway analysis relies on the
kaijin's knowledge base relies on a set
of over 8 million findings
and where our curation team has manually
curated the literature to understand
molecular interactions and associations
as well as the contextual details of
those interactions and associations
and so with this data set when we have a
set of variants with loss of function we
have the ability to understand
the genes for which these loss of
function variance occurring what
pathways might they be related to
and what we're looking at here is
something we call networks so taking
this set of genes that have loss of
function variance and asking
based on our known set of interactions
for these genes from the knowledge base
what are genes that could occur in an
interaction network across my set of
genes so how they might uniquely
interact together in this context of
this cohort of lynch syndrome patients
so essentially each line here represents
how these two molecules would interact
based on what we know from the
literature
and so within this interaction network
we can actually take our set of genes
that we've defined that have a
likelihood of neighbors of interactions
that could uh overlap with each other
and we can look at different functional
aspects that are enriched for in this
set of genes so in this table to the
right hand side we can see lots of kind
of familial
uh cancers that show up here we can also
see lynch syndrome in particular um and
a number of other things but
this gives us some functional
understanding
now you also notice each of the molecule
nodes on here is green that represents
that in fact these genes show a loss of
function in the variant data
now with this information we can
actually take this pattern of loss of
function in these genes
and utilize
what we call analysis match in ipa
employing
90 000 plus
comparisons from public studies that
focus on gene expression to ask the
question
in what
studies do we see gene signatures that
show a similar loss of expression of the
same set of genes i just showed in my
network
and so to do this we utilize something
we call the activity plot
and within this plot very simply we have
what we call the z-score on the x-axis
and that's our metric for similarity and
dissimilarity very simply
values above two typically represent
where the gene sets overlap between our
variant data and these expression
studies that the pattern of expression
of the genes recapitulates that loss of
function in our gene set that we observe
from the lynch syndrome study
and so within this we can select points
that show a high degree of conservation
in this
loss of activity for a given set of
genes and when we select these points we
can get a list of studies here we'll go
into this a little detail in the
software
and from this point any of these studies
we can now ask a question when we see
this pattern of expression change
overlap with our loss of function
pattern
what genes show concurrent loss of
function and a decrease in expression in
these studies and so this translates us
back to this heat map that we saw in the
beginning
so what i'd like to do now is actually
take you through the process of
interrogating this data lastly within
ingenuity pathway analysis
to do so
i'm going to open up the software and
again i've
forgotten kind of going through the
steps of uploading and analyzing the
data that's already been done in advance
just for time purposes
what i want to focus on are the results
of the core analysis and i have them
open here for this particular data set
so we can see variant effects analysis
within lynch zone lynch syndrome this is
encompassing our loss of function genes
and when we run this core analysis we'll
get a number of biological endpoints but
one critical one might be trying to
understand the pathways that are
associated with these set of genes that
have loss of function variants
so in the summary page of this analysis
the first tab at the top left what we'll
see are top hits with regards to
canonical pathways we can see role of
bracha 1 and dna damage response
hereditary breast cancer mismatch
repairing eukaryotes dna double strand
break repair by homologous recombination
all different characteristics of dna
damage we associate with lynch syndrome
mutations so it's a good kind of
biological confirmation of our findings
and in fact we can interrogate this
information in further detail
by simply clicking on the canonical
pathways tab
so what we're seeing here is essentially
a bar chart where the height of these
bars represents the enrichment of my
gene set that have loss of function
variance
and you'll notice this first bar has a
coloring
that is a prediction based on the loss
of function of these genes that we'd
have inhibition in this particular
pathway
but you can see here again in this i'll
just rotate this to a horizontal view
again the pathways that i mentioned that
we would expect perhaps to be associated
with um
mismatch repair mutations and lynch
syndrome uh bracha one in dna damage
response
you can see mismatch repairing
eukaryotes
and then also dna double strand break
repair by homologous recombination
non-homologous recombination the
nucleotide excision repair pathway right
all logical pathways in the context of
our phenotype of interest
now for any one of these pathways
we can simply click on the bar
and in the associated table at the
bottom
what we'll see are the set of genes
from our data set that have the loss of
function variants that fall within again
the pathway that i have selected here
role of bracha 1 and dna damage response
so this table will give us some general
annotation about these genes
we can click on the gene symbols to
actually pull up what we call the gene
view page all the information we have
curated on a molecule so you can learn
more about that
and then also at the tail end of this
table to the far right we have those
genes that are known biomarkers and
genes that are targetable by drugs if
any
so from this point what we can do if we
want to visualize this pathway in
further detail we can actually click the
open pathway button
we can interrogate where within the
structure of this pathway we see changes
or loss of function variance
and that would be represented by all the
nodes in this network
that show a green coloration so these
are observations in our data set
and we can actually do predictions based
on these observed loss of functions very
simply by going to overlay
selecting the tool molecule activity
predictor
and what we're going to do here is
utilize this observed loss of function
and what we know from the literature
and the directionality of the
interactions with these loss of function
variants with other molecules in the
network actually predict
what we would expect the activity of
other molecules in this network to be
so very simply i'm going to click start
prediction here
and we're utilizing information from the
literature to now color the majority of
these other nodes that you can see in
blue here which represents a predicted
loss of uh activity and inhibition in
these molecules and again this might be
representative changes at the dna level
sorry not the dna level the the protein
level or the transcriptional level for
instance again predictions we're doing
based on the literature
but very nicely based on these
predictions we'll also notice that
specific nodes
that relate to functions within this
pathway are changed including homologous
recombination and ultimately
dna repair
so overall we have a nice efficient way
in which we can interrogate the pathway
context in which our loss of function
variants are
influencing different key canonical
pathways
now the other aspect i want to briefly
show of the software is very simply
what i alluded to in my slides it's
found under networks and here we're
utilizing an algorithm to identify for
the sets of molecules that we have in
our signature of loss of function within
lynch syndrome how might these molecules
be composed of interaction neighborhoods
how might they interact with other
molecules in our list or other key
molecules perhaps not captured directly
within our list
and so we use all the interaction
information available in the knowledge
base to actually build these networks in
a data specific data set specific
fashion
and again just like with the pathways
what we have the ability to do is
visualize the associated interactions
within the networks again here i pull up
a network
this is not a canonical pathway but a
network of interactions based on my loss
of function genes
all these edges again represent
literature evidence of interactions in
some fashion between the molecules
and
so i can get some context understand
with an existing understanding bio of
the biology of lynch syndrome try to
understand why these molecules might be
interacting in a certain context
but what i can also do is look at
perhaps the functional consequence or
the phenotypic consequence of some of
these molecules
simply by going to overlay and selecting
diseases and functions
so what we're doing in this context is
taking this interaction network instead
of molecules and looking to see
is there enrichment of any functional or
phenotypic category that might be
relevant to uh my cohort of interest so
again here we're looking at lynch
syndrome um again we're pulling on the
knowledge base so this will calculate
and essentially once it completes we can
see all the categories of functions that
are enriched for
and what i just want to highlight to
everybody is in particular here we see
hereditary disorders lots of hereditary
cancers show up in this list
as well as
different functions related to dna
replication and to associate the genes
in my network with any of these i can
simply click
add that function to the box
and now i know what genes let's say are
explicitly associated with repair dna in
this network
so that's one kind of quick
interrogation of this data looking at
what's in my study but to get to our
final point for today
we might now ask the question with this
observed network and the pattern of loss
of activity or loss of functions of
these genes in this network
do we see the signature show up in
expression data in public studies
and to answer that question we'll simply
click on this button here for pattern
search
this will generate the activity plot
that i showed in my slides again here
the key takeaway is that the points that
fall to the far right represent
gene expression data sets that show the
same set of genes with decreased levels
of expression
and
points to the left which is opposite of
our pattern of loss of function these
are data sets in which we'd expect
increased expression our set of genes
very simply here
i can grab let's say all the studies
that show a value above 2 again a
confident prediction in a match
and as i select these points what i will
generate at the bottom here is a table
of all the studies again that show
conservation of the signature and
decreased expression of these loss of
function uh variant containing genes
so within this table lots of different
characteristics that capture essentially
to the right here the case and control
criteria that are used in the comparison
as well as details about the overall
comparison
and for any of these studies as i click
on the rows
to the top right here i'll get details
about the context of experiment here
this is a comparison between two
treatments
uh it's looking at pancreatic cancer
it's done on ngs
here attributes with a control sample so
epithelial cells
the case samples and also a link to the
pubmed
study itself and also the link to the
geo page for this publication
so this data set has essentially been
pre-analyzed in ibm we have this for
over 90 000 public study
comparisons now
i can then kind of go through this list
there are many kind of scenarios where
we see similarity but one overriding
theme that i observed when looking at
this is that many of these studies show
treatments with some kind of uh compound
that induces dna damage so kind of makes
sense and again most of these are
cancer-related studies
now the last step here would be to
select any number of studies that i deem
relevant i can just select them within
the table and now open up this gene heap
app to ask the question
we see conservation of
this loss-of-function pattern in our
data set with regards to gene expression
in public studies now what specific
genes
whose loss of function are identified in
my data set in network one in the first
column in this table actually show
decreased expression in any of these
studies
and what will generate is this heat
map-based view where as i scroll down
i'll start to see a number of
genes within a cluster here
that would say that they show mlh1 again
a lot of the fancy family of genes
praca those all have loss of function
variants in my lint syndrome cohort
and very interestingly across these
studies again different cancers treated
with dna damaging agents
we see that these genes in fact show a
decrease in expressions of the green
cells
across each of these different columns
so now i have some insights and i can
explore this further
when we talk about public comparisons we
have lots of different comparisons
available in the context of as we're
looking at here many treatment-based
studies but also disease versus normal
responders versus non-responders but
hopefully this represents a way in which
we can integrate loss of function
information
from a variant
based study to gene expression patterns
within public data sets
so with that uh i'd just like to
conclude i'd like to mention again
everything that we've looked at today
really falls under our kaiogen discovery
insights portfolio
we talked about earlier using the
kaiogen clc genomics workbench to move
from fast q to identification of
variance and then for interpretation
purposes we talked about at the variant
metal level kaijin clinical insights
interpret translational and ingenuity
pathway analysis
and ultimately hopefully what i've shown
everyone today is that we've walked
through this step of going from fast q
files
using clc genomics workbench to analyze
and call variants that are accurate and
with confidence
from there using hygiene clinical
insights interpret translational to
prioritize those variants both within
samples and across a cohort that are
pathogenic and in this case represent a
loss of function of a given gene set of
interest and then lastly utilize
ingenuity pathway analysis for discovery
taking that gene set with the loss of
function variance in determining what
pathways are relevant
how does this loss-of-function signature
relate to gene expression signatures in
various public cancer studies
so with that i'd like to thank everybody
uh for listening in today and at this
point i will open it up to any questions
that you may have
great thank you so much eric that was a
great presentation thanks for walking us
through all those steps and putting
those pieces together again last chance
to ask some questions here today we've
got a few questions here in the queue
uh let's start off with this first one
um
can we use it to check somatic
variations for tumor samples without the
new without the normal reference i have
ngs sequence data available for only 40
tumor samples with no normal data
yes so in the genomics workbench we have
pre-built pipelines for workflows that
can run in either of two contexts for
somatic data so to your scenario if you
let's say are missing a match normal you
can call variants um and perhaps you
could employ a filtering step where you
look at those variant alleles that are
in db snip you can filter them out to
perhaps remove germline variants or you
can look at variants that have
expected kind of allele frequencies 50
for heterozygotes 100 for homozygotes
you can filter those out as well if you
choose and try to get at those variants
within a sample without a match control
that are somatic variants and then
conversely we do have kind of workflows
in place if you would in the future have
paired tumor normal data how we can
filter out the observed variance in the
normal from the tumor samples
got it great thank you
another question here
does
kaijan clinical insights perform
analysis on microbes for virulence or
metabolic genes for example
uh so currently the curation efforts for
the knowledge base are focusing on
human data sets so um essentially it
would fall under the context of two main
areas hereditary disorders uh looking at
human germline data that we curate from
the literature and through third-party
databases and um
also then somatic changes so again all
of this is in the context of human data
specifically for variants so uh the
answer short answer would be no um in
the context of at least clc genomics
workbench it definitely has the
flexibility to at least call and look at
let's say amino acid changes in
microbial variants in that context so
for the interpretation aspect again
primarily focused on
human hereditary and somatic diseases
got it um
does
ingenuity generate uh pcoa plots
pca plots
it uh does not so um really ingenuity
pathway analysis is built for
interpretation
so if you wanted to let's say do a
principle component analysis there are
abilities to do that
specifically in the context of gene
expression data within clc genomics
workbench
yeah okay great and then uh looks like
maybe the last question
for heat maps does ingenuity have the
ability to cluster according to
different metrics including manhattan
etc uh so currently the clustering uh
i didn't show that with the heat map
that i showed we do have clustering
based on different criteria
i think there is one option i can't
recall off the top of my head for
hierarchical clustering so it's just one
of those metrics i believe euclidean uh
by default and then there are also other
metrics based on patterns that you might
expect across studies or
um
basically uh scoring of different
categories but for higher hierarchical
clustering there's only one metric
that's used um when we employ that in
ipa explicitly
yeah got it
uh actually
last question looks like they just came
in
well
can we analyze ngs sequence data
directly in ipa or is it complementary
to
the kyogen clc workbench
so it is complementary to the workbench
um with ingenuity pathway analysis as
you saw today we could bring in a list
of genes with gain or law gain or loss
of function variants and more commonly
as you saw through the public data sets
the typical starting point in ipa would
not be
raw sequencing data or even quantified
expression in samples but rather
differential expression
right or study
yeah yeah i think the best way to uh
think of that is that your clc genomics
workbench is for your secondary analysis
which gets you to that differential
expression and then ipa takes it over to
take that differential expression and
we'll just use that term broadly it
could be you know protein expression you
know obviously mrna expression micro rna
et cetera um and uh and then analyze it
there in ipa so
with that we are at time
thank you so much um oh eric are you
still with me
oh never mind i we did answer this
question i thought we had a last minute
question but no we we uh we took care of
it so
with that i'm gonna say thank you and
goodbye to everybody that concludes
today's session bye